l'habitat troglodytiques est l'atout
majeur du village de trop sur sept
niveaux
une vingtaine de troglos sont toujours
habités il yal habitations troglodytes
c'est une invitation un petit peu à la
mode on va dire beaucoup d'artistes qui
sont installés ici
et puis c'est une douceur de vivre vous
avez l'impression d'être dans un petit
cocon et c est plutôt agréable
vous n'avez pas les bruits extérieurs
quand les fenêtres sont fermées
c'est très agréable à flanc de coteau
aux bords du loir
la municipalité est fière de présenter
son petit patrimoine acquis au fil des
siècles
là ça va donner quand un accordeur un
coup de projecteur sur le village le
faire connaître puisque c'est un village
comme très insolite très particulier
mais qui manque
manque 2 qui a besoin d'être plus
beaucoup plus reconnus et ben dis donc
ça fera venir un petit peu plus de
touristes patron jusque là non plus
parce que nous n'avons pas
d'infrastructures qu'ils permettent à
partir d'une vieille légende entre une
femme bavarde et le diable le puits qui
parle a été remis à l'honneur en tombant
elle aurait creusé ce depuis ce mercredi
soir à 21h sur france 3 vous pourrez
retrouver la commune de trop dans
l'émission le village préféré des
français nous ont fait un voeu un voeu
pour la commune de trop que vous soyez
finalistes